he said do me a favor go home to your
wife talk it over and call me tomorrow I
said I'll do that but I'm not gonna
change my mind and she said what do you
think about talk radio I said I know
nothing about it other than it seems
shallow glib and stupid she said it is
you'd be good at it
[Music]
hello and welcome to the sunday special
this week I am super happy to welcome to
the show Larry elder who is actually the
first guy who ever interviewed me on
radio of course world-famous radio host
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let's talk about an
uncomfortable fact you're gonna die I'm
that we're all gonna die
I know but life insurance is a topic
that you need to know something about
because you need life insurance whether
you're an insurance expert or a newbie
policy genius has created a website that
makes it easy for you to compare quotes
get advice and get covered policy genius
is the easy way to get life insurance in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find the coverage you need
at a price you can afford from there you
just apply online the advisers at policy
genius will handle off the red tape for
you they'll even negotiate your rate
with the insurance company no extra fees
no Commission sales agents just helpful
advice and personalized service and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy whether you're shopping
for disability insurance to protect your
income or homeowners insurance or auto
insurance they can help you get covered
fast so no matter how much or how little
you know about life insurance you can
find the right policy in minutes at
policy genius.com it's the responsible
adult thing to do policy genius the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance go
check them out right now you need life
insurance to make sure that your family
is taken care of in case god forbid
something should happen you go check
them out policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance all
righty well Larry thanks so much for
joining the show really appreciate it
thank you for having me I appreciate it
so for folks who don't know I mean and
very few people do Larry was the first
radio show I ever did I was 16 years old
I was going to UCLA Larry was a host at
KABC at the time in Los Angeles and I
had written a piece in the in the daily
Bruin about basically being
discriminated against by the daily Bruin
and Larry had me on a show to talk about
it and we've been friends ever since so
it's been nearly 20 years which is
insane but Larry in his own right is one
of the great voices in talk radio for
decades in a full decade and a half
before I ever met Larry I managed to
listen to him on the radio so Larry what
for folks who don't know you why don't
you tell your story because obviously
it's a unique one how you go from you
know growing up in the inner city or the
stage from south central to becoming one
of the bigger voices on the conservative
slash libertarian right well it
certainly wasn't planned I'm born and
raised in LA as you pointed out and I'm
a lawyer when ii went to college in the
east coast of brown I went to Michigan
for Law School
and I worked for a big law firm
cleve in Ohio I stayed there for about
two and a half years I did well but I
was kind of restless and bored and it
seemed to me like it was too small of a
platform for me I wanted to get into
commentary some sort of way but I know
how to do that so I left the firm and I
started a business not because I wanted
to be a headhunter which is what I did
because I thought I could make more
money doing that than practicing law and
I did and then I was able to spend some
time and start writing columns didn't
have a deal didn't have a syndication I
just wrote columns and sent them to the
local newspaper the Cleveland Plain
Dealer and the air can be concern 'el
the two biggest newspapers in Northeast
Ohio which is where I was living and
every now and then one would get
published and finally I one that I wrote
about thirty years ago where I argued
that racism was no longer a major
obstacle for black America and to say
that now it still raises eyebrows let
alone 30 years ago so I the plain deal
to publish the article I get a phone
call from the producer of a radio show
do you really believe that racism is no
longer a major problem in America I said
yeah he said when you come on my guys
Joe tonight and talk about it now then
Cleveland is about 50% black so
virtually every caller was the black
person and they were not happy and I got
called an Uncle Tom bootlicking Uncle
Tom foot stuff like bootlicking Uncle
Tom bug-eyed Uncle Tom a coconut Oreo
the Antichrist and that in that word
that you really call a black person when
you really want to cut him Republican
and I said this is a waste of time I'll
never do that again I get back to my
office the station a manager calls me
and he says you were amazing I said I
was oh you were funny
you have a good speaking voice you took
difficult positions you defended them
effectively without losing your sense of
humor have you ever thought about doing
talk radio and I said no and he said
I've got a guy going on vacation next
week Lee you stood in for him and I said
no I mean and I said why and I said I
don't like it I don't like being yelled
at I don't like yelling back at other
people reminds me of a conversation with
my little brother Dennis I still not
interested he said are you married at
the time I was he said do me a favor go
home to your wife talk it over and call
me tomorrow I said I'll do that but I'm
not gonna change my mind so I went home
and I talked it over with my then wife
Cindy and she said what do you think
about talk radio I said I know nothing
about it other than it seems shallow
glib and stupid she said it is you'd be
good at it
and so I I said really and she said yeah
you're always moaning and whining and
giving your opinion you might get paid
for it so I did that week and after 20
minutes I heard angels sing I mean the
Red Sea parted I mean it was it was it
was magical and I said I got to do this
and so it took me two years to to write
and cajoled and meet and ultimately I
met Dennis Prager by accident
Dennis had me on his radio show he
praised my performance and I said to
Dennis if you really think that I'm that
good
could you please recommend me to
management I've been trying to get into
to radio for a couple years then I said
I'd be happy to and did so George Green
heard me and after one night he made me
an offer he said he gave me a two night
audition he didn't call it that but I
knew that's what it was and he said
after the first night do you want this
job I said yeah I think I do
he said okay go out tonight relax stay
the course and don't speak so damn
quickly so that word about myself a
little bit that was my yeah you're the
only one who speaks better than I did
and and that's really what started it
and I started 1994 I think it was and
I've been on radio ever since
so what formed your political viewpoint
because obviously taking the position as
a black person in America that racism is
not the key factor in American life or
even a key factor in American life's
pretty controversial position where did
you get that from it's pretty rare
position I got my dad my father my
father I think he didn't get along my
father and I had a huge fight when I was
15 years old and we didn't speak for 10
years and when I say didn't speak band I
mean did not speak not like hi dad and
that's it I didn't say a word to him and
I graduated from high school and I was
able to then go to college on the East
Coast and law school in the Midwest so
basically when I had bought it my dad
for almost 10 years now my mom my dad
just we're still married in the house so
when I come home for vacation for
summers I would just make sure I'm not
around he's not around and that was
pretty easy because my dad worked long
hours he had a cafe so now I'm a fast
forward it's 25 years old I've now
graduated from law school I have this
big job with the big law firm making a
boatload of money on 25 years old and I
should be living large but then I can't
sleep and I know it has something to do
with my dad not that I ever thought we'd
be buddies but I call my secretary and I
said cancel all my appointments
I'm flying to LA
I'll be back in a couple of days I
didn't tell my parents I was coming
because I didn't want my father to
prepare for this summit so I get to the
airport DRI get a cab to the to the
restaurant I got in at 1:30 we close at
2:30 and I came there with these two big
bags my dad hadn't talked to me in 10
years he sees me he's course surprised
he said should I put your bags in the
back Larry I said no dad only gonna be
here for five or ten minutes I want to
tell you something he said okay wait
till we close i sat there for an hour
and I said to myself Larry don't tee off
on the son of a just give him the
highlights don't don't just wail into
him and so my dad sat down and I wailed
into him for almost 20 minutes you see
how I can go and I talk for 20 minutes
about every spanking every whipping
everything he ever said to me everything
he'd ever done to me that pissed me off
and I gave him everything and I was
exhausted I'd run out of ammo my dad
goes is that it you didn't speak to me
for 10 years because of that and I went
yeah and my father said let me tell you
about my father and Ben for the first
time I saw my father cry I did not think
the man had the ability to summon tears
I think he could do that I knew my
father was an only child I knew we had
no relatives because on his side because
we never got any gifts for Christmas
aside from that I knew nothing about my
father I met his mother once when I went
to the South but I knew nothing about my
dad and didn't care I didn't like him my
brother's didn't like him either so it
wasn't like that
I was curious about him so he said let
me tell you about my father when we're
sitting in these two stools in my dad's
cafe he said your last name elder I said
yeah he said that's not the name of my
father I said what what is your father's
name he said I have no idea you never
met your father know who's elder he was
in my life the longest my mother had a
series of boyfriend each one more
irresponsible than the other one elder
was a drunk seldom worked and when he
did he'd take home the money give it to
my mother so that she would keep it so
he wouldn't drink it away and then come
Wednesday or Thursday he'd want it if he
didn't give it to him he kicked the crap
out of her if ever I tried to do
anything he kicked the crap out of me
and he was in my life my dad said the
longest how long was the longest he said
four years I said what afternoon after
that series of boyfriends I'm now 13
years old my dad said I came home from
school eighth grade and I was making too
much noise for my mom's then boyfriend
my mom and sided with the boyfriend when
he and I were fighting and she threw me
out of the house
age 13 never to return Athens Georgia
Jim Crow South at the beginning of the
Great Depression I defy you to find
somebody with the hand dealt like that
my father goes down the road Ben he
picks up trash does anything he can do
ultimately he becomes a Pullman Porter
for the trains they were the largest
private employer of blacks in those days
and so he was able to travel all around
the country which was eye-opening for a
little black board from the south and he
came to California one time on a run and
it was sunny and people seemed to be
less races he could walk into a
restaurant and get served and my dad
said to my mom maybe someday I'll
relocate to LA Pearl Harbor my dad
joined the Marines he was the first
black Marines they were called the
Montford Point Marines people don't know
they know about them but they were every
bit as influential as where the Tuskegee
Airmen everybody knows about there were
20,000 Montford Point Marines from 1942
and 1944 t 9 and Congress gave them a
question of gold medal a few a few years
ago my dad got his posthumously anyway
he was stationed in Guam they came a
staff sergeant was charging in charge of
the cooking facilities he can cook
anything he could look at a cake and
tell you what was in it so he goes to
Chattanooga where he'd met married my
mom and he knocks on doors all these
restaurant to get a job as a cook and
they told him we don't hire to his face
he goes to an unemployment office lady
says you went to the wrong door he goes
to the hall he sees colored only goes
through that door to the very same lady
who sent him out he came home to my mom
and said this is BS I'm going to LA I
may get me a job as a cook and I'll send
for you comes out to LA walks around for
two or three days I'm sorry you have no
references and my dad of course told
them that he was a World War two vet he
cooked for the service I'm sorry have no
references my dad even offered to work
for free just give me a written
reference they wouldn't even do that
they treated him the same way in LA as
they did in Chattanooga there was a
little more polite about it
he went to an unemployment office one
door sat there in a chair for a day and
a half late calls him up I have a job
don't know if you're gonna want it my
dad says I'm sure I'm gonna want it what
is it and she says cleaning toilets with
a company called Nabisco brand bread my
dad did that for ten years took a second
job cleaning toilets at another Bread
Company called Barbara Ann bread cooked
for a family and Pacific Palisades on
the weekends it went to night school two
or three nights a week to get his GED
the man
never slept been an hour here two hours
here you do that week after week month
after month year after year and you come
home with a with a household full of
three rambunctious boys and see what
kind of mood you're in the man was tired
and so we talked for eight hours I asked
him everything I could ask him he asked
me about my life the man got bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and I got
smaller and smaller and smaller by the
end of the hour eight hours I'm crying
and I said dad I am so sorry
and he said Larry don't be just follow
the advice I've always given you and
your brother's hard work wins you get
out of life what you put into it
Larry you cannot control the outcome but
dammit you are 100% in control of the
effort and before you moan and whine
about what somebody did to you go the
nearest mirror look at it and say to
yourself what could I have done to
change the outcome and finally he said
this no matter how good you are how hard
you work how moral you are sooner or
later bad things are going to happen to
you how you deal with those bad think
will tell your mom and me whether or not
we raised a man so I wrote a book about
it called dear father dear son the
reason for the title is because after
this 8-hour conversation I fly back to
clean my father rose surprise me a
letter he never brought me a letter in
his life and it said dear son and
rolling back and I said dear father I
never called him father before and so
then we began this relationship that
lasted 35 years and arguably even closer
than my mom and I were my mom and I were
very very close so I was able to to
salvage my relationship with my father
and have 35 really good years and the
book is called dear father dear son to
live eight hours and it's on paperback
also called a lot like me we changed a
title it's because people thought it was
a collection of letters and the
publisher realized that that turned off
people it's really a it's a novel it's
read almost like a novel but it's a it's
a book of memoirs well it's an amazing
story and it does lead to the question
which is I mean your dad obviously
enormous ly tough individual just from
the story and and you're a tough guy too
in the sense that you've taken an
enormous number of slings and arrows
over the years to take this position why
do you think it is that so few folks in
mine not just the black community the
Hispanic community a lot of various
minority communities tend to not move
along those lines tend to tend to not
suggest that the first indicator of
success is individual decision making
but the first thing that we have to
overcome as society's institution
racism or some sort of miasma of
discrimination that is preventing people
from achieving their goals it's a
complicated question but but it starts
with the family and I know it sounds
counterintuitive because my father had
no family but if you don't have a family
role model inside the house father
inside the house you're in trouble out
of the gate and 70% of black kids today
are born to unwed mothers and the number
25 percent in 1965 and what we've done
with our welfare state and the so called
war on poverty which Lyndon Johnson
launched is to incentivize women to
marry the government and allow men to
abandon their financial and moral
responsibility and the the the black
kind of victimhood mentality is a
phenomenon of the civil rights movement
going from demanding equal rights to
demanding equal results and that's what
we have right now people are demanding
equal results results have to be earned
rights will come from God and so people
like Jesse Jackson and the commercial
black caucus and the n-double-a-cp and
this whole cabal of organizations
telling black people that their victims
is a huge part of the problem
how do you think that conservatives
should go about speaking to black folks
obviously because that's been a serious
issue every time somebody tries to
engage with the black community they're
their folks on the Left who particularly
start calling them those people racists
I suggest their pandering or and that's
because nobody really wants to tell the
truth Cory Booker just the other day
said he wanted to have an honest
dialogue about race no you don't if you
have an honest dialogue about race you
don't want to hear it to me the most
dangerous race hustler in America is not
Sharpton he's bad not Jackson he's bad
not some of the Yahoo's you see on cable
television they're all bad but it's Eric
Holder because people listen to Eric
Holder he's sophisticated he's got
degrees from from Columbia undergraduate
and in law school works for a very
prestigious law firm was a respected to
the left AG he says the most outrageous
things and gets away with it for example
he gave a speech in which he talked
about Prentiss's racism this is around
the time that Donald sterling lost his
team remember he was taped by his
girlfriend and made some disparaging
comments about blacks and ended up
losing his team and Eric Holder said
that kind of blatant racism that kind of
blatant bigotry we got that that's not
the problem
the problem is the pernicious racism and
he gave
examples none of which hold up the first
example was the push for voter ID polls
show that about 80% of whites one voter
ID and about 7% of Hispanics do about
the same number of blacks do and there
was a study recently by researchers from
Yale from Stanford and from Penn and
they looked at the research paper that
purported to show that voter IDs
suppress black and brown votes and they
trashed the methodology these other
researchers used instead there's no
evidence whatsoever that these voter ID
laws suppress black turnout furthermore
2008 when Obama got elected for the
first time in history despite all these
alleged voter suppression efforts the
percentage of eligible black voters who
voted exceeded the percentage of
eligible white voters who voted so it's
nonsense the second one he gave is that
black kids are expelled at
disproportionately high rates compared
to their percentage of that given school
and it's true that they are Jesse
Jackson some years ago sued the Decatur
school board which was all white because
they kicked out a bunch of black kids
who were fighting after a football game
turns out the kids had missed
collectively like three four hundred
days of school anyway they kicked him
out in comes Jesse Jackson accused the
school board of racism thousand lawsuit
school board defended itself by pointing
out that at other school districts where
the school boards are primarily people
of color black boys are still distantly
kicked out and they mentioned Oakland
which was primarily of school board
members of people of color San Francisco
also the majority of the school board
members were people of color and yet the
black boys were kicked out far more
compared to other people when you look
at their percentage in that given school
so it's just a lie and the lawsuit was
thrown out the third thing that Eric
Holder said is that black criminal
defendants who commit the same crime
will get a longer sentence than white
criminal defendants and that's true but
the us sensing Commission says the
reason for that is that judges take an
eccentric consideration on the time of
sentencing your criminal history and
other factors for example whether or not
you have a working history whether not
you show remorse all those factors so
even the us sensing Commission to which
Eric Holder referred said you can't
conclude one way or the other whether or
not biases is operating here there could
be all sorts of factors to explain this
so though that's the best you can do and
this is the frontrunner guy who's
articulating the the racism in America
all you could do was come up with voter
ID and this expulsion stuff and the
sentencing stuff he'd even say they were
dis personally arrested didn't even
didn't even come they're coming near and
they're saying that so it's a lie and he
said all these things and people sat
there and they politely listen to it and
it seemed respectable and nobody
challenged it except for me I wrote an
article about each one I wrote one about
the expulsion rates I wrote one about
voter ID and I wrote one about
sentencing all right so Larry I'm gonna
ask you about a philosophy that seems to
have taken over the Democratic Party
almost wholesale and that is the
philosophy of intersectionality as a
precursor to that I want to get your
opinion on the legacy of Barack Obama
because it's my opinion that
intersectionality really became a thing
under the Obama presidency people tried
to blame president from for the rise in
increased racial tensions in the United
States room but if you look at the polls
what the polls say is that Americans
were pretty optimistic across the racial
spectrum before Barack Obama became
President Barack Obama became president
and then things started to sink pretty
quickly and I think a lot of that has to
do with the fact that Americans elected
President Obama under the auspices of
who's going to be a great uniter
somebody who tried to get us beyond race
he in his own persona was a unification
of black and white considering his
father was black and his mother was
white right this is what he ran on and
then instead of coming forth and saying
listen we can all call out racism
together when we see it but not every
problem is a race problem a lot of
problems are just people problems and
maybe we should do that instead of him
doing that he decided to build an
intersectional coalition around himself
and then suggest the people who
disagreed with him were inevitably
racist I want to get your opinion on on
Barack Obama's impact on sort of the
race debate in the United States you
know I was in the Boston arena in 2004
when Obama gave that speech for John
Kerry and he brought the house down
I was with my producer and people were
cheering there's no blue America there
is no red America that just United
States of America yeah there's no black
where yeah and I said to him this guy's
gonna run for president he's gonna get
elected he didn't say a damn thing but
he said well and so Bromley gets elected
and you're absolutely right I believe
that people voted for him in large part
because they thought that he was going
to put the nail in the coffin that
America is a racist society finally we
can now move on a number of people I
think pull the lever for him because
that and he proceeds to do just the
opposite
before he became president he gave a
speech as a senator at a church in
Atlanta and he was talking about how
much racism there is in America and he
said the generation of MLK the Moses
generation has quote gotten us 90% of
the way there
close quote to realizing MLK dream of a
society where people evaluate you based
on content of character and I thought
that was reasonable 90% 10% of Americans
believe that was is still alive eight
percent believe any similarity he'll get
it seven percent of adults believe that
chocolate milk comes from brown cows
twenty-five percent of adults say
they're not sure so you can't get much
below ten percent and then he said the
generation my generation the Joshua
generation he said has to get us that
additional 10 percent that was before he
got elected let alone reelected let
alone back-to-back Attorneys General who
are black so I would think that 10% has
been worked into just a little bit when
he ran in 2008 you wouldn't find him and
Al Sharpton on the same plane together
second time he ran our Sharpton come to
the White House something like over 70
times over the course of his of his
presidency the first opportunity that
that Obama had to reconcile to do what
people thought he were going to do was
the Cambridge police incident you
remember that the professor from Harvard
had forgotten his door key he was on
vacation came home realize didn't have
his door key and he and the cab driver
pushed the door and broke into his own
home a neighbor sees this calls 911
don't you want neighbors to do that cop
shows up very politely ask a skip gates
to come out of this house and he
constitute and says something like I'll
come out of your mama tells me to come
out and instead of Obama going on
television saying look skip I know
you're a friend of mine you and I've
been friends a long time but you have
done exactly the wrong thing for for
young black boys instead of being
respectful instead of responding to the
request you copped an attitude this is
exactly why a lot of young white people
are getting killed by the police because
they look at this as a confrontation
instead of following instructions my
father told me when I pulled over by the
police make sure your hands at ten
o'clock your your right hands at two
o'clock you say yes sir say no sir
make sure your paperwork is in order
and if you feel you're mistreated get a
badge number write it down and you and I
will deal with it while we're both still
alive that's what Obama could have said
and should have said and did instead he
said the Cambridge police acted stupidly
and the cops then realized that he was
not on their side
and Obama thumbing around with that
stupid beard thing to try and walk it
back a little bit but they also hidden
yet several chances Trayvon Martin if I
had a son he would look like Trayvon I
didn't know what that even means
and of course Trayvon Martin was found
not guilty and the jurors said race
never even came up there were no blacks
on the jury but there was a black
alternate and the alternate said he
would have voted the same way not not
guilty and race was not a factor Obama
gave a speech before the United Nations
and invoked Ferguson now this is why
Ferguson was still being investigated
this cop was assumed to have been a
racist a Michael Browns allegedly had
his hands up don't shoot and Obama
mentions this to a United Nations
address and says we have our own
problems a place called Ferguson
Ferguson turned out to be a complete
force as you know and the DOJ comes in
exonerates the the the cop but
nevertheless says that the Ferguson PD
is institutionally racist and their
biggest takeaway was this 67% of the
population of Ferguson is black 18% of
those who are stopped for traffic stops
or black 18-point gap ergo racism the
Ferguson PD they had two or three blacks
outside of that there were 50 whites if
that's true why isn't the NYPD even more
institutionally racist 25% of black
people live in the $0.25 population of
New York is black 55 percent of the
traffic stops or of black people that's
a 30 point gap yet the majority of New
York cops or either women or people of
color so how come that isn't it isn't
more racist and the answer is you can't
do it by numbers you have to do it by
differences in offending and there's a
report that came out in 2013 under the
Obama administration by the National
Institutes of Justice which is a
research arm of the DOJ called race and
traffic stops and they looked at this
75% of the black motors admitted that
they were stopped for legitimate reasons
and the Commission found that
differences in offending and differences
in driving accounted for the difference
couldn't find any evidence of racism
years ago in New Jersey black motorists
were being stopped Dysport Lee by the
New Jersey Turnpike
Jerzy troopers and they were yelling and
screaming about racism Christy Todd
Whitman ordered a study study came back
and said the faster the car the more
likely it is to be a black guy couldn't
find any evidence of racism didn't like
the study didn't like conclusion and
threw it out hired a different person
different methodology same conclusion
sorry just not there these things have
been measured and studied over and over
again
every two or three years leo J conduct
something called the police public
contact survey can't even stop by the
police how are you treated are you black
are you white what did anything happen
nothing no no pattern it's just a lie
and so people like like Eric Holder the
n-double-a-cp
of Barack Obama have been perpetuating
this BS lie and admit in my opinion they
do it because they want that 95 percent
monolithic black vote without which they
cannot succeed and if black started
thinking of themselves as individuals
and not as as a aggrieved group and
start looking at things like the crappy
public school that I'm mandated to go to
job-killing laws like minimum wage they
would rethink their assumptions with the
Democratic Party and their democratic
party is definitely afraid of that and
that's why they have to malign people
like Larry elders Uncle Tom's and and
slam other people as as racist because
you cannot get 95% of people to think a
certain way unless you lie to him well
speaking of speaking of that one one of
the ways that this this has been
intellectualize is in this philosophy of
intersectionality and the philosophy has
been put out there basically that
historically a lot of groups in the
United States specifically black people
most of all obviously have been
victimized by the power hierarchy the
hierarchy was set up for that end then
the only way to fight back against that
power hierarchy and institutions of
power is to band together in groups that
think they can get then get together
themselves and then attack that
hierarchy and tear it down from the
inside out
the only way if you are on the top of
the power hierarchy or if your white
male for example the only way that you
get out of this unfortunate situation is
by acknowledging and reading time he
codes apparently the problem with all of
this is that in order to escape poverty
you get to the middle class if this has
been studied by the left and by the
right and they agree if you look at the
Brookings Institution and the Heritage
Foundation there are diametrically
opposed on many issues but on the
to get from the poverty to the middle
class they all say the same thing
finish high school first number two
don't have a kid before you're twenty
number three get married before you have
the kit and they phrase it a little bit
differently but that's what all three of
them have said and if you argue that as
Obama did that a kid raised up his
father is five times more likely to be
poor nine times more likely to drop out
of school and 20 times more likely to
end up in jail that is the number one
problem facing America and if slavery
and Jim Crow
I had this effect how do we go from
having 25% black out of wedlock birth in
1965 to almost 70% now I would think
that anybody would argue were less
racist today than we were in 1965 so you
can't attribute it to that in fact
during slavery a black child was more
likely to be to be born under a roof
with his biological mother and
biological father then today it is the
number one problem facing this country
not racism take a magic wand and wave it
over America and remove every smidgen of
racism for the hearts of white America
50% inner-city dropout rate in some
schools 70% of black kids born outside
of wedlock as I mentioned 25 percent of
young black boys have criminal records
the CDC just said that a young black man
is 10 times more likely to be the victim
of a homicide compared to a white person
and the number one cause of preventable
death for young white men are accidents
like car accidents the number one cause
of preventable cause of death for young
black men is homicide almost always at
the hand of another black person Chicago
a third black a third white 1/3 Hispanic
70% of the homicides are black on black
and about 75 percent of those men are
unsolved and we're talking about
intersectionality get out of here get
out of here so let's talk about
Republicans and their take on these
issues because one of the big problems
that you see with a lot of young people
and a lot of minority groups and and a
lot of minority folks is they have a lot
of problems specifically with President
Trump I won't get your take on how
President Trump has handled racial
issues because you know to be perfectly
frank with you I am not completely
comfortable with President Trump if she
was of race I think they who's
completely comfortable with Trump at all
come on well yeah after with Trump he
may be the only person who's completely
comfortable at President Trump but the
rap on him he's obviously been called
racist by a large number of people who
are running my opinion of that is that
he is a man who says many ignorant
things because he is not the kind of
person
as non-human things but but obviously he
shot himself in the foot on a lot of
these issues with things like
Charlottesville with his with his casual
kind of winks and nods at the alright
during the 2016 election what's your
take on Trump on race well first of all
you have to understand that as a
Republican president he's going to be
called racist if Donald Trump had not
gotten elected in somebody else's
Republican head Mike Pence whoever might
have been running the he or she would be
called racist Reagan was called racist
maxing fort waters called George Herbert
Walker Bush a racist a George W Bush was
called a racist so they're always called
racist Donald Trump is a whole another
level I will give you that but they're
always called racist so the idea that
Donald Trump is being called a racist
should not surprise anybody because
that's how they roll
he hasn't helped any by some of the
comments that he's made but that said I
had a call at the other day who told me
I was quote always defending that racist
in the White House close quote
black collar and I said all right let's
cut to the chase tell me the number one
thing that that that Trump has done that
you considered to be racist number one
thing he's done or said he said he says
that black people are lazy
I said you're referring to a book that
was written by a disgruntled fired ex
Trump employee even one of the liberal
fact-check organization couldn't confirm
that comment that we have he said well
the the 1975 consent decree that he had
it into where he admitted that what he
didn't admit anything but he was accused
by the FHA of discriminating against
would be black and brown tennis now he
had black and brown tenants he didn't
want it to the least to a certain
category that he thought couldn't
couldn't pay couldn't pay the rent and
he was sued and they entered into a
consent decree didn't admit any guilt
lasted for two years he was 28 years old
at the time he took over from his dad's
business so was dad's business practices
that he was that he was following and
after 1975 go on YouTube and you'll see
pictures of Trump with Jesse Jackson
Trump without Sharpton Trump with John
Johnson the editor of Ebony magazine
Trump with all these local black leaders
so if the 1975 to consent decree didn't
bother them it shouldn't bother me
either and it doesn't I don't know any
large landlord who hasn't been sued and
by the way the Washington Post just
settled a lawsuit
claiming racial discrimination by a
disgruntled long-time ex-employee who
got fired CNN is right now fighting a
lawsuit by a group of people claiming
discrimination as is the New York Times
so bring me somebody with clean hands
and we'll talk that's all the guy had
and you know the comment about the good
guys on both sides he didn't say that he
was referring to the battle over whether
or not Confederate monuments should be
in the public square that's what he
meant and he's a sloppy speaker and so
it's easy for somebody to take that word
those words and interpret it as saying
there were good Nazis and bad Nazis he
didn't say that and he renounced David
Duke many many many times I don't know
how many more times you have to do that
doing something about illegal
immigration to me is a big boon to black
people
George Voorhis is a Harvard economist
where you went to school and he says
he's he's probably done more research on
the impact of legal and illegal
immigration anybody else in the country
there's no question that unskilled
illegal immigrants take away jobs from
inner-city black and brown people who
are unskilled and puts downward pressure
on their wages Donald Trump was to do
something about that and that makes them
a bigot the other thing is this
inner-city parents want vouchers they
want to say I don't want to send my kid
to Larry elders alma mater Crenshaw High
School we're kids right now only 3% of
kids can do math at grade level
what responsible parent would send their
kid to a school where only 3% of the
kids there can do math at grade level
nobody would but you don't have any
money you'll have any options if you
live across the street from Crenshaw
high school your kids going there
whether you want to or not and by the
way it's a school meaning the Crips
run it I know that because I ste went
there ten years after I did and that's
why he chose the school because he won
in a school that is run by the Crips who
would send their kid to a school that's
run by the Crips and we're only 3% of
kids can do math at grade level if they
have an option the Democrats are wedded
at the hip with the teachers union don't
want to give you an option they want to
give you a voucher z' Republicans do so
if the crowd to the middle class is to
get an education and the Republicans are
giving me a better route to that why am
I gonna call this guy a racist how does
that make him a racist if that's racism
he need to go back to racism school re
sona ask you about your sort of
libertarian philosophy so you started
off as a libertarian you know I'm small
EO you re right you weren't a member the
libertarian party never have been right
so you you've never met a member of the
libertarian party know why because of
their position on foreign policy
basically libertarians believe if you
leave people alone they'll leave you
alone and if life were like that
wouldn't it be wonderful but it is we
have a group of people called
Islamofascists that are determined to
start a caliphate and they believe that
you have three options if you're not a
Muslim you can convert you can pay a tax
or you can be killed and believe it or
not there there are probably about ten
percent of Muslims 1.25 1.5 million or
so of them that believe this philosophy
if you look at polls that show how
people felt about 9/11 it's scary how
Muslims in France and Muslims in in
Britain felt about 9/11 we've got
enemies there was a funny exchange in a
program called 24 a few years ago
William Devane played the Secretary of
State and he had a son who was an
activist anti-war activist a peace
activist an anti-nuke activist and he
had this conversation with his son his
son was trying to convince his father
that what his father was doing immoral
was immoral and he said spare me your
fifth-grade Michael Moore logic America
has enemies we have enemies and the
libertarian party seems to believe that
if we just mind our own business other
people mind their own business
that's a bet I'm not willing to make one
of the things that's been fascinating is
watching as the Republican Party and
conservatives more generally have moved
in a more libertarian direction on a
variety of issues one of the issues
where you were way ahead of the curve
was on drug legalization so where do you
stand on drug legalization particularly
as we look at the heroin epidemic that's
currently occurring do you think that
drugs should be legalized as far as hope
leads where do you draw the line I've
always felt that the drug problem there
is a drug problem
I should be dealt with as a as a public
health problem not a criminal justice
problem it's also a libertarian problem
if I want to destroy my body and put
stuff in it I own my body not the state
I should have that right to do it we
ought to be counseling people about
appropriate behavior and that sort of
thing but criminalizing something like
this has always bothered me so milton
friedman's felt the same way and made
the same argument so the the
counter-argument kind of pushback and I
have to admit I'm very torn on this
issue so I'm a libertarian level I agree
with you the counter-argument I think is
somewhat compelling which is that there
are obviously drugs like opioids that
actually brought people of the capacity
to reason these are lifelong addictions
and so treating it as a public health
problem as opposed to something that
actually affects the ability to act in a
Liberty
anyway libertarianism assumes that
people have the capacity to make
reasonable decisions and if you're
basically allowing an enormous
percentage of the population or even any
percentage of the population to be
turned into mental or reason reason
based invalids they can't reason anymore
is that is that a decent
counter-argument to that I don't think
so because a downside is even worse the
drug epidemic has also caused an
increase in street crime it's been
estimated that about 50% of street crime
is directly or indirectly related to
people robbing and maiming and stealing
in order to get money for drugs
people going into prison and you come
out you can't get a job now because
you've had a record the amount of money
that society loses because of the theft
the higher cost of insurance premiums
because of all the theft related to
drugs you know there are lots of other
unintended consequences because of this
war on drugs and so know even though
some people will misuse their freedom as
they always will the idea Thomas
Jefferson used to say if people misuse
their freedom the idea is not take it
away from them but to better explain to
them how they can better put their
freedom to use we should be doing okay
so with all that said how do you grade
the Trump administration on their
approaches because it's been kind of
fascinating there it's big government
administration they've blown out the
spending right they've actually
increased enforcement of drug issues
they've they've not been libertarian
with regard to labor so you mentioned
earlier that you think the president
Trump's crackdown on illegal immigration
is good for black workers in the United
States because you obviously don't have
a greater supply depressing the wage
base on a libertarian basis should we
care about that should we care about you
know here yeah I mean Milton Friedman
used to say you can't have open borders
when you have a welfare state well that
we've got a welfare state and the
average illegal alien according to the
Center for Immigration Studies cost
taxpayers over the course of the illegal
aliens life about 80 grand it seems to
me we ought to have a say in that so but
putting aside the welfare state if
you're a libertarian on it on labor then
the idea of additional supply would
lowering the wage base shouldn't really
be a libertarian problem meaning it
should be a problem if taxpayer dollars
are being expended to support people
that's a libertarian problem but it's
not really a libertarian problem people
want to come here and work and then move
around and then leave should it well it
is a libertarian problem because because
you to me you're not just bringing your
your work you're also bringing your your
politics and your culture
and it seems to me that we have a right
to determine who comes into our country
whether or not that person or persons
feel the way we feel do they share our
our belief in a separation of church and
state do they share our belief in a
limited government I don't want people
who don't I believe the the reason for
is the borders are porous right now it's
because eventually these illegal aliens
turn voters are going to pull the lever
for the Democratic Party if the
Democrats believe that illegal aliens
turn voters would pull the lever for the
Republican Party we wouldn't be having
this conversation we wouldn't be talking
about statehood for Washington DC we
wouldn't be talking about allowing
convicted felons to vote all of these
things breed more Democrats wouldn't be
talking about college free tuition if it
weren't the case that the more likely it
is you go to college if you're studying
humanities the more likely is you're
gonna come out more liberal than when
you went in if college meant that you
were more likely to come out as a
Republican or conservative Democrats
wouldn't be pushing this so this is all
about votes turn a libertarian basis to
go back to sort of the Trump question if
you had a great president from where
would you grade him so far in his
administration compared to what compare
compare it compared to president Hillary
Clinton compared to President Larry
elder I assume that I think we all have
an objective standard in our head of how
you a great president so for example you
know you give George Washington in a you
give FDR and F you give Ronald Reagan a
- or B plus so on that sort of scale
where do you put President in Trump's
I'd probably give him about an a-minus
maybe b-plus far better than I thought
he was going to be far better I don't
like the tariff stuff but it hasn't been
as bad as I thought it was going to be I
I do think that I under played under
paid attention to China and what China
was doing in terms of stealing our
technology and it was right that
somebody finally did something about
that I love the tax cuts they should
have been steeper the idea that they
eliminated state and local deduction and
eliminate and put a cap on mortgage
interest deduction I didn't help Larry
elderly but the idea that overall
Americans got a tax break I'm happy with
that I'm happy with the Supreme Court
justices that he's done I'm happy with
what he's doing about sanctuary cities
or trying to do about sanctuary cities
in catch-and-release on some of these
other policies I don't like the Visa
Lottery system and I think we ought to
have people coming in on on merit and so
all the stuff he's doing on immigration
I like I don't like the paid Family
Medical Leave
but his daughter said that in Cleveland
and 26
during the RNC I heard her say and Trump
has since repeated it he's not a
conservative he is a populist he's not a
fiscal conservative he's not a social
conservative he's a populist he's got a
collection of views and values you add
them all up it's better than president
Hillary Clinton when he ran I said this
I said if Donald Trump were a movie he'd
be the good the bad and the ugly and
about ten days after that I'm watching a
news show and Melania is on and she says
if Donald were president he'd be the
good Donna would a movie he'd be the
good the bad and the ugly and I said
where's my ten percent the the ugly is
when in my opinion he said that george w
bush lied us into the iraq war however
you feel about that war he did not lie
us into the war and i campaign with
donald trump and I met him in Cleveland
we campaigned at a black church and I
said to him there's one thing that
you've said that I think you should
apologize for any thought I was gonna
say the John McCain thing when he said
John McCain was captured and I said no I
said you said George W Bush lied us into
the war I said I know you didn't like
the war but he did not lies in the war
that's what the left says that is one of
the big stains right now on the
Republican brand that george w bush
decided he wanted me it would be a
wartime president just just fabricated
all the in for all the entail so he
could build a case for the war i said we
have 16 agencies at the time all sixteen
said at the highest level of certainty
that saddam hussein had not only WMD but
has stockpiles of WMD all 16 george w
bush held this kept the same CIA
director George Tenet had served under
Bill Clinton he told him that the idea
that Sodom is saying had WMD stockpiles
was quote a slam-dunk
close quote we just gotten hit 3,000
people that died george w bush looking
around is find out what are the next
level of threat if he had done nothing i
would argue that that would have been
irresponsible and and so for you to say
that he lied in to the war my goodness
Isis the same nonsense that the people
on the left are saying he went but he
never said it again and my watching of
Donald Trump is his way of apologizing
is not to say the same stupid thing
twice but he won't say I'm sorry so with
all of that said you know President
Trump has given I think conservatives
way more than we could have expected one
of the reasons I didn't vote for either
candidates the top of the ticket in 2016
is because I didn't
expect him to govern as a conservative
he didn't campaign as I remember
remember you're not you and I had had
long conversations oh yes and and he's
obviously done a lot better than I
couldn't I couldn't persuade I said I
think he's not gonna be as bad as you
think I know you're right and I was
wrong so that that's listen I could not
be more happy that I was wrong about his
policies I don't think I was wrong about
his character and I think that that has
not changed I think he's the same person
he's in his seventies he's not gonna
turn into saint anytime soon or anything
close to it isn't amazing we have we've
had two divorced presidents one was
Ronald Reagan and then one was Donald
Trump not only was he divorced he's been
three marriages in the marriages appear
to have overlapped some of the others
Plus these other activities as my
colleague Dennis Prager says it shows
you that God has a sense of humor the
question that I that I still have and I
you know I've said this before
I'm significantly more likely to vote
for President Trump in 2020 than I that
I was in 2016 there is a math under
which Trump's presidency ends up being
for me a net loss and I'll tell you what
the math is the math is that we get all
this good stuff we get the tax cuts get
the Supreme Court justices we get the
movement of the embassy in Jerusalem we
get we get a strengthening of our
military all the good things and I
acknowledge all of them and I'm very
happy about all of them which is again
why I plan on probably voting for him in
2020 but let's say that he he himself is
so toxic to a large percentage of the
American people that let's say he loses
in 2020 he loses the presidency in 2020
we no longer control the House of
Representatives we lose the Senate in
2020 and suddenly you have a unified
government under Kamala Harris or Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren right and a
lot of that is driven by backlash
specifically to President Trump is that
a math that we should worry about or is
that basically just at this point what
is what is is he's gonna run he's gonna
run for reelection we have to deal with
it much of the attack against Donald
Trump I think is unfair
I mean 90% of the news against him is
negative and yet the economy is blooming
like this 69% of people think they're
going to be better off next year than
last year and still he's being hammered
like this I think we need to call the
media out for their unfairness even the
when when Obama ran in 2008 the humble
person for the Washington Post her name
with Debra Howell she's no longer there
she admitted
we had more pictures of Obama on the
front page we had more flattering
pictures of Obama on the front page more
stories of Obama on the front page more
flattering stories of Obama on the front
page
we didn't she admitted it so I really
think that a lot of the the fear that
you have about Donald Trump is generated
from the unfairness of the media and of
his coverage and if we call him out on
it and defend him when he needs to be
defended I think he can get get
reelected right now he's riding pretty
much where he always has in low-40s an
approval rating his never surpassed 50%
he's never on the lower end surpassing
the spires and Rasmussen is the outlier
pulpit in the in the real Club politics
poll average and even and even in Gallup
he's now a couple of points since his
State of the Union yeah that's right I
mean it but he bounces around but he
seems pretty stable he has he is ceiling
he has a floor
he doesn't tend to move around too much
in between those things and in 2016 that
didn't hurt him in the sense that
everybody thought the election was gonna
be a referendum on trumpet back to back
to Rasmussen he's now about two or three
points higher than Obama was at this
juncture of Obama's first term right III
really I'm happy to acknowledge the
Rasmussen polls I like the poll average
is better just because better average
has me better data but but as a general
matter his approval ratings aren't that
high it didn't hurt him in 2016 people
just didn't show up to vote for Hillary
Clinton right you look at how he's
performing in the polls right now in
some of the swing states that he I mean
he he pulled the rabbit out of the hat
in 2016 just statistically speaking and
that that's an amazing thing you're what
we're still analyzing what happened in
2016 yeah I think another underestimate
thing that happened that did not - yeah
how big is people didn't see it coming
that's a hundred percent right they're
ready now well they are ready everybody
every person under a rock who's eligible
to vote he's gonna vote left-wing
they're gonna find him or her totally
agree I mean if you look at the
statistics my contention has been that
there is a myth that both Democrats and
Republicans have been living under and
it's skewing the political process the
myth is that President Trump was a
transformational candidate in 2016 if
you look at how he performed he actually
performed in percentage percentage terms
within once two points of Mitt Romney
and George W Bush in virtually every
state meaning that he actually performed
like default Republican it's just that
he never got a lower percentage of the
white vote than then he got fewer
absolute votes in Wisconsin than Mitt
Romney did in 2012 and he won Wisconsin
because no one showed up to vote for
Hillary because number one she's
terrible at number two everybody thought
she was gonna win
Kratz did show up in the last midterm
right Republicans too - and Democrats
blew out Republicans which makes me
skeptical more skeptical I think of his
chances in 2020 but again because
Democrats have reacted too strongly to
Trump they're attacking all the way to
the left/right with candidates who are
saying insane things legitimately every
day so I don't mean to make you
prognosticator but if you have to bet
odds on Trump but that's the saving
grace that they're overcorrecting
Alexandria LoCascio Cortes is the base
of this party I don't mean she's a
leader but I mean her ideas or the base
of this party medicare-for-all getting
rid of ice $15 minimum wage college free
tuition this new green deal this is what
this party has become part of it is
response to Trump but part of it is just
a normal more normal insanity of people
on the Left who are emotional don't look
at sex so I think that's a real that's a
real gift the other thing is this as
with Ronald Reagan
people underestimate Donald Trump I
remember watching the State of Union
speech I thought it was a good speech
not a brilliantly it's not a great
speech but a good speech but because
people think of him as a doddering idiot
they're going nuts oh my god great
speech great so the fact he's
underestimated I think it's a real
secret weapon that he has as well all
you have to do is behave I'll just do
stop tweeting as much all used to do it
look more reasonable to people that's
that's not a difficult stretch I mean
that's I've been saying people in the
White House if he just is quiet and
points figures of the Democrats just go
like this the entire election cycle and
he should be he should be okay
you know with all of that said you know
the heat and he's so funny
he is raining he is entertaining I mean
who watches a Town Hall the whole thing
i watch this whole thing he's cracking
me up he's entertaining he's having fun
and the economy is doing well people
feel safe where in the world are we
worse off because of because of Trump
not it not in the Middle East not not
not not China not Korea where are we
worse off and the answer is nowhere the
country is better off in the last two
years because of Donald Trump and so I
think when people calm down and when
there's a binary choice Kamala Harris or
Elizabeth Warren or Cory Booker versus
Trump Trump wins okay so let's talk for
a second about the expansion of
executive power because there's a
libertarian this is something that's
been happening under under both parties
parties President Trump has continued
that trend right the amount of spending
under President Trump has increased it
has not decreased so size and scope of
government continued to increase
with the Republican president surprise
you because when they campaign in 2016
neither Hillary nor Trump said a damn
thing about the entitlements even Obama
said the Italians were unsustainable and
I said this at the time I said no matter
who wins four years from now eight years
from now the debt is gonna be much much
higher because no one wants to rein in
Social Security or Medicare or Medicaid
there's a third rail and one of the
things that Trump did one the reason he
got elected - it's because unlike other
Republicans who always at least talk
about the entitlement programs he didn't
say a damn thing about them and so
people that were worried about that went
okay and so he pulled over some
squishies some independents some
so-called conservative Democrats because
of that had he gone out and said what I
would have said which is we have to
privatize Social Security we have to go
with health savings accounts for for
Medicare and we have to get rid of the
the federal government's taking of money
and giving it back to you for welfare we
should get rid of all of that that's
what I as a libertarian believe and I
would never get elected because of that
Donald Trump understood that people
don't wanna hear about cuts you get
somebody something once they don't want
to take it they don't want it back you
ask people who argued that government is
too big and then you put down specific
programs you want you want to cut this
cut this no no no no no the Gerber is
too big check the taxes are too high but
raising taxes on rich people not a
problem so I'm gonna get your opinion
because this week the president declared
a national emergency on the border it's
my opinion that as a constitutional
conservative that this is not what the
executive branch was designed to do was
basically declare legislative proposals
even if I agree right what the the thing
he's attempting is you where do you
stand on the national emergency I think
that he had no choice if if he's sincere
and believing that the border presents a
national security crisis and I believe
he is since there because of the border
crossings are down doesn't mean it's not
a night of crisis the fact we've ignored
it for 30 years doesn't mean that
because it's not as big as a deal is
about 30 years ago it's not a major
problem so I think if Donald Trump
believes that this is a national
security crisis as commander-in-chief it
seems to me he has should have the
ability to do what he needs to do to
defend the country that means declaring
a national emergency to moving some
money around I'm okay with that this is
not it's not a phony crisis I know that
the left believes that it is but I don't
think it is I had a real problem with
what Obama did with with daca I mean
here's here's Obama bragging that he's a
con law professor teaches at University
of cago I'm sorry I can't use an
executive order to do all
things you guys want me to do uh
liberals I'd love to do that says Obama
but I can't and then he gets pressure
and then all of a sudden he does exactly
what he said he couldn't do that
bothered me a far a lot more than than
what Donald Trump is doing what Donald
Trump is doing it's for national
security at least he says so with a
straight face Obama could not make that
argument regarding daca okay so in one
second I have one final question for you
I want to ask you specifically you've
mentioned that the libertarian ideas if
they're the right ideas they may not get
us elected they may not get we may not
have libertarianism anytime in the near
future have property I'm gonna ask about
how we bridge that gap in just a second
if you want to hear the answer you have
to be a daily wire subscriber subscribe
go over to Daley where com click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation there no Larry alter it's
always a pleasure to see it and it's
great to have you on the sunday special
thanks for stopping by
my pleasure thank you
[Music]
Avenger Pierrot shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan case hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera title
graphics by Cynthia and Guillot the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
you